what's going on guys this is rob and man
let me tell you guys something okay
inferno is here and here's the thing we
need to get caught up man all right so
here's a slope this week we're just
going to dump x-men content i know i've
said that before we're actually going to
we're just we're going to dump a ton of
x-men stuff so that's that's something
to look forward to everybody on patreon
i apologize we're gonna postpone patreon
stuff because honestly we just don't
have enough time for it all uh we're
just we're gonna we're gonna get caught
up on the x-men where we get caught up
on all this stuff because oh inferno is
amazing okay so i'm i'm very very
excited for this after this is done i
think what we might do when we have like
all the stuff completed is we're gonna
do a full story from the beginning of
house and powers of x all the way up to
the end of inferno right this is the end
of the three-part act right this is this
is where hickman's done he moves on he
goes to three moons three worlds
whatever it is right and just kind of
calls it a deck i'm curious to see how
long this full story would be i feel
like it'd be like like over 24 hours
i have no idea if that'd be the case or
not but what this does this initially
opens up with the orcis forge right now
remember the orcish forge because it's
been a while since we talked about this
the orcish forge is the headquarters of
essentially orcis itself and orcas is a
coming together of a multi-faceted group
of people right like advanced idea
mechanics hydra just the government in
general right like just normal human
scientists all these people working
together for the purpose of what is in
effect destroying the human threat and
what this does is it focuses on what is
basically the x-force team wolverine
domino uh kid omega right quentin choir
these guys are highly capable and as
they get in there they're immediately
met by the arrival of of nimrod right
now this is one of the most important
things about the character of nimrod we
talked about it before but it bears
refreshing here right nimrod has the
ability to analyze a mutant to know what
their powers are and then develop
basically counters to their powers so in
the case of domino domino has the
ability to bend probability to her favor
in a localized field so what does nimrod
do he says solution cluster bombs with
quantum targeting which number in excess
of the combat area basically overwhelm
her powers to the point that there's no
conceivable means for her to escape and
ultimately it works one of these bombs
bonds itself to to domino and she gets
blown to pieces following that it goes
to quentin choir right kid omega nimrod
analyzes him mutant possesses
omega-level telepathy as well as some
telekinetic ability threat level
enhanced processing cores at risk
solution rotates ionic shields and phase
shift cores into secondary host then
disintegrate target before he can
overcome defenses i.e clinton choir can
dominate the minds of both man and
machine so basically create more minds
that he can dominate at any one
particular point in time and moves so
fast that he can't react and that's
exactly what happens right like
literally nimrod starts phasing through
his mind basically to the point that
quentin choir can't dominate it and then
while that happens create a second
version of himself to attack quentin
choir from behind and then he says that
just leaves and then yes right wolverine
the last man left right busting him
busting out his adamantium claws tearing
a hole through through nimrod and then
he's just easily incinerated by those
robots and then it's just stop freeze it
there and that's when you basically pick
up with orcas as these guys are talking
to each other right you've got dr greger
remember she's kind of like the
scientific person the one that really
seems to be the most hell bent on
destroying the entirety of the mutant
population and then director devo who's
the one that's kind of running the whole
thing and the question director devo
asks is after 16 times that they've come
here and tried to destroy us and nimrod
what have we learned that's something to
know the x-men have tried this 16 times
and they've done a variety of different
things they've they've brought in
different teams they launched a brood
invasion remember broods are basically
aliens from another dimension that
deposit their eggs in and then those
eggs essentially take over the host and
then create more brood and it doesn't
matter right nimrod still takes them all
out every single time the x-men launch
an attack against orcas they get
destroyed over and over and over again
and as they've analyzed this the one
thing that they began to pick up on when
the questions asked again what have we
learned is that dr greger hypothesizes
that these are clones that these are
basically the same people who are being
sent here right because the bodies are
being taken and you've got multiple
versions of wolverine now that's one
thing to know that orcis and the rest of
humanity don't know that the mutant
population has the ability to resurrect
themselves they don't know that they
don't know about the five the
resurrection gardens all that kind of
stuff they don't know about any of that
kind of stuff right all they know is
that seemingly these are clones or
duplicates doppelgangers something like
that but somehow or another the x-men
are able to duplicate themselves and
they've just been sending teams here the
second thing they've learned is that the
x-men the strikes that they're engaging
in are basically the same which reveals
a huge revelation here that while orcas
is advancing they're becoming more and
more capable they're quelling these
x-men threats faster and faster every
single time they're launched the x-men
threats always come in the same way
which means they don't remember when
they were here before and that's when
the the statements made by another
person is simply saying no it's not
entirely they don't remember someone
remembers that's why they keep coming
here somebody keeps sending them here so
what you end up doing is you switch over
to maura mctaggart right at the time
that she creates basically the cure for
the mutant race and when this cure is
created and she's basically thanking all
the other scientists here there's a
colossal explosion which is very very
similar to the one that we saw from days
of future past back in the day basically
everybody's killed except for maura
mctaggart and she's met by the arrival
of mystique and destiny this is a huge
thing because this is actually the third
life of maura mctaggart if you guys
recall from house and powers of x that
[ __ ] mctaggart has lived multiple lives
now the way that that was explained to
us by jonathan hickman is that at most
she has 11 lives and that she could just
kind of continue living those lives
basically forever and ever and ever and
ever right she's like 11 in at the time
that we go from house and powers of x
into the actual launching of dawn of x
right everything that's happened over
the course of the x-men mythos so far
has been the eleventh life of mormon
tagging i'm pretty sure it's the
eleventh one but so the question has to
be asked here how long can this go on
for if that's her mutant power it's to
basically be resurrected and always come
back but remember everything from her
past life then how can she how could she
possibly be destroyed and that's one of
the things that destiny talks about now
remember destiny's dead right so this
obviously takes place before destiny's
death but she's dead at the moment right
now so she's not really a threat that
you have to worry about but in this life
that she has when she's talking to maura
mctaggart and she says like you would
think there'd be no way to kill you you
would think there'd be no way to destroy
you but understand i've seen your future
i know what can happen and i know how to
destroy you and so what you end up
learning here is that the only way to
kill maura mctaggart and she stays dead
forever is to kill her before her powers
manifest if you kill her one second
after her powers develop she'll
reincarnate right like a fraction of a
second after her powers emerge she'll
reincarnate but if you kill her when
she's like eight years old she'll just
be dead she'll never be able to come
back but the question that destiny has
here is that in looking at maura
mctaggart what she sees is that
seemingly maura mctaggart will always do
this now this is the other side of the
equation that we never saw during house
and powers of x for whatever reason that
was never really given to us more
mctaggart had always worked on creating
like a mutant cure she had these
different escapades happening over these
different realities but we didn't know
why it is that she suddenly went from a
person who was looking to cure the
mutant population or looking to reduce
the mutant population and not
necessarily work against them as an
enemy but offer a way for mutants to
become normal humans to suddenly being a
person that's like mutants have to
survive we didn't know the answer to
that question right it just simply just
happened that way right it's one of the
things we even mentioned during house
and powers of x and so what you get in
this exchange between destiny and mora
mctaggart is destiny says understand
every time that you're reincarnated i'm
there we are linked every time that you
come back you have memories of what
happened in the life that you had before
you die and so something to understand
here i see your future right and every
single time that you're reincarnated i
exist in whatever that life happens to
be and i know everything that happened
so i know everything that's going to
happen to you so i know whether or not
or i will know whether or not you will
try to create a mutant cure whether or
not you will try to be some kind of a
monster and destroy the mutant
population so she says when she reveals
to her you can be killed as a little kid
it's kind of a threat right sort of a
sort of a threat that she says like we
know how to destroy you we know how to
make sure that you can never reincarnate
you can never come back to life you can
never enjoy this process of living out
an infinite number of lives in an
infinite number of ways just going on
forever and ever and ever until the
universe dies of heat death and so she
says if you ever over the course of
these lives that you live however many
times that you die if you ever become
the person that creates a formula that
will find some way to destroy the mutant
population if you ally yourself with
people who will destroy the mutant
population if you do anything other than
help us thrive i will be there and we
will kill you and we will kill you
however many times we need to it doesn't
matter so she says change right become a
person that helps the mutant population
grow and thrive especially because you
and i both know that this this existence
of the mutant population will inevitably
always lead to a war with machines or
with man or combination of both because
she says do you really believe that
humanity will just let you have this
formula right that you will have this
formula out there to cure the mutant
population and humanity will say okay
cool well we'll just let the mutants
that want to stay mutants we'll let them
kind of continue doing that and those
mutants who want to become human or want
to lose their powers will let them do
that too no humanity will take that cure
from you they'll weaponize it and
they'll use it to get rid of the mutant
population so she says as long as you
are out there as a person that's doing
this you are an existential threat to
the mutant population's entire existence
and so when the question becomes how do
we ensure that you are that kind of
person how do we make sure that you know
to never work against the mutant
population lest you die in a horrifying
way the response that mystique gives is
i think the answer is fear and so
destiny says perhaps there's only one
way to find out and so what she does is
she summons pyro right remember pyro is
a mutant that has the ability to
manipulate fire he cannot create it but
he can control it and she tells pyro
kill mora mctaggart burn her but do it
slowly so she never forgets what
changing feels like right make sure she
suffers slowly and painfully that was
maura's third life now it goes into
myra's tenth life right the current one
that we're seemingly in right now so i
guess it's really this one as opposed to
the 11th life but the important thing
here is that as we kind of continue on
we switch over to maura's no place right
maura mctaggart you switch over to the
no place the places she exists in in
krakowa where seemingly nobody can get
to where she is right it's basically
underwater right where nobody would
really know that it's there nobody would
know how to access it but when she
arrives through her cohen gate she's met
by the arrival of charles xavier and
magneto now here's a very very important
distinction and set of events that
unfold here that one of the things that
was kind of given to us is that as the
x-men mythos exists right now by way of
house and powers of x it's all
predicated on the idea that at some
point in the future there will always be
a war between the mutant population and
seemingly everybody else either it'll be
post-humans right so those individuals
those children of the vault that we've
talked about before in the x-men mythos
or it'll be humanity orcus who have
basically created nemrod who will wage
war against the mutant population in one
way or another it always leads to a
massive conflict and every single time
mutants are totally destroyed and so it
always seemed to be that this entire
concept was basically an organization a
kind of agreement and even a friendship
that was struck between charles xavier
more mctaggart and in magneto what we're
basically given here is this idea that
there's trouble in paradise man one of
the things that happens is that there's
a statement that's made by charles
xavier right like let's not reminisce on
the past right it doesn't help anything
or or anything along those lines and as
the two of them are kind of talking
suddenly that dawns on maura mctaggart
like wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute reminiscing about the past like
what are you talking about like like the
two of you were here after i after i
came back through my did you know that i
left and that's when they revealed that
what they had done is is during the
initial meeting of the quiet council
when they had fed her tea they had
secretly put nanobots in her body that
it actually coalesced in her elbow that
were developed by forge so they could
always know where she was they don't
really trust her they don't really trust
her at all they kind of take her at her
word because the threat that she
presented seemed to be such a
significant threat that they had to take
it seriously right because charles
xavier read her mind and realized she
was telling the truth but the honest
truth is that they never wholly believed
her the other part of this is that in
the conversation that they have the
statement made by maura mctaggart is you
have to destroy nimrod and you have to
destroy destiny destiny can never be
allowed to come back destiny can never
be allowed to return if she does it
would mean the end of everything but
given the context of the beginning of
the story that doesn't really seem to be
the case at all it seems like maureen
mctaggart's lying right she's just
saying that so that she can kind of live
out her life the way she sees fit and
then in turn never have to worry about
destiny which begs the question if
that's the case if morgan mctaggart
approached charles xavier and said all
these terrible things are going to
happen in the future we got to do
something you know bill corker and all
that kind of stuff is what she's doing
actually setting the x-men on on a
collision course with humanity and
ensuring the mutants destruction that's
the question that you have to ask
because that's one of the things that
magneto and even even xavier himself
talks about right they say like okay so
here's the thing right like regarding
nimrod and and the robots and all that
kind of stuff every single time we
launch an attack that it basically has
done nothing more than allowed humanity
to create these things right so our
actions have really put humanity on the
path of creating nimrod right but we did
that at your behest because you said it
was going to happen and we had to
prevent it from happening from there it
goes into the discussion of mystique and
the idea is that with destiny having
been a love interest of mystique i mean
i guess it wasn't necessarily solidified
but it basically was right by all
standards of measurement marvel told us
that mystique and destiny have really
had a love interest in each other for
quite some time that with mystique being
in a position of power she will
inevitably lead to the return of destiny
and so in order to ensure that doesn't
happen mystique has to be removed from a
position of power but arbitrarily
getting rid of somebody who's part of
the quiet council with seemingly no real
motivation given is not an easy thing to
do because while they are on the quiet
council and while they were founders of
the quiet council the quiet council
itself was founded under the notion of
equality that every member of the quiet
council is equal to every other member
right this is not george orwell's animal
farm where everybody's equal but some
are more equal than others it's not like
that right at least it's not supposed to
be that way but what they're basically
really planning here and what what uh
morgan mctaggart is telling them here is
you need to find a way to get rid of
mystique right sell it on a season of
change right say things are changing
around here everything kind of changes
we're celebrating you know the the
progression of our mutant population and
so what they do here and this is
actually a pretty shady situation is the
statement is made here by maura
mctaggart right she says yes mystique
has to be erased she says by now
everyone knows the process of how a
mutant is returned from the dead what is
required is for you to seize the means
of resurrection the five of course
cannot be controlled in any such manner
however the mechanisms by which the
process begins and ends can be control
of the cradles is paramount and she says
but more important than that is whose
hand's resurrection begins i want you to
collect what remains of destiny's dna i
want you to collect it and i want you to
destroy it destroy every ounce of it
destroy it all will you do that for the
future of our nation will you do that
for me literally they're going to just
destroy the existence of destiny right
preventer from from ever coming into
existence this is pretty shady right
this is a pretty shady thing for
somebody like charles xavier or magneto
or anybody to be doing and to a degree
it really seems to be predicated on the
belief that what more mctaggart is doing
is trying to ensure the future survival
of the mutant population and so in
response to this charles xavier says as
a show of good faith a symbol of our
realignment we will and then more
mctaggart responds don't lie about this
it's what keeps me up at night it's the
one thing i truly fear and i haven't
slept peacefully for a thousand years i
cannot will not accept her breathing
curcumin air i want her gone forever
burned from all existence and so that's
kind of a crazy thing here is because
they're basically plotting to remove
mystique from power so mystique can
never advocate among the quiet council
the return of destiny because seemingly
mora mctaggart's the only one that
really has anything to fear from destiny
and even if she passed on this notion to
xavier into magneto that the return of
destiny could lead to the destruction of
the mutant population nobody else in the
quiet council would have any reason to
believe this because they have no
interaction with moore mctaggart and so
if mystique is able to create a
compelling enough case and saying no
having somebody who can see the future
coming back can help us in ways that we
can't possibly imagine because she will
allow us to counteract threats before
they ever become threats in the first
place right to prepare for what was
previously an unforeseeable future that
she's far more of a benefit than she is
a liability that would sway the quiet
council and ensure that destiny is able
to return and so in order to initiate
this whole thing this whole process of
removing mystique from power they start
to kind of bring in again this whole
idea of a season of change that you have
cyclops basically stepping down from any
real position he was in before and
simply saying i can offer myself as a
captain but i cannot be a commander
among the quiet council anymore that my
job is to be a field member of the x-men
team i just can't dedicate time to this
anymore and being a commander requires a
lot of time and dedication and so where
cyclops steps down bishop replaces him
right bishop ends up becoming a
commander which is a cool moment right
bishop was just a ridiculously cool
character who never got his due let me
tell you something man under the right
circumstances bishop is overpowered man
this guy is so cool i love the character
of bishop but he ends up becoming the
new commander following that you switch
over to the quiet council and them
having their meeting and that's when
xavier and magneto go in for the kill
that's when they go into yes it's a
season of change everybody it's a season
of progress we're evolving as we always
do we as a mutant population stand as
the representatives evolution among the
human race and how can we possibly imbue
this idea of evolution if we ourselves
do not evolve therefore we need to
evolve the quiet council we need to
evolve this role the quiet council place
and even magneto goes as far as to say
if it's the will of the council even i
would be willing to step down if it was
required even i would be willing to
accept this evolution and move to a
lesser position and so ultimately the
two of them turn their sights to
mystique and mystique's like you know
what that's a great idea guys we've got
an open seat on the quiet council and i
100 agree it's a time for change right
until she says i know a mutant we should
consider for the council and the
response of xavier is like what and then
magneto tries to cut her off and says
there'll be a time for that but as a
member of the quiet council she can call
a vote on anything anytime she wants to
so long as the rest of the council will
let her and she says the time is now the
time for this for for the calling of
this meeting is now i offer a candidate
for this council who sits in dominion of
the mutant island of cocoa come forth
mutant and that's when you get that line
that's when you get that phrase that was
told to mystique there will be an island
not the first but the last this place
will seem to be hope for our kind when
those days come remember these words
bring me back and if you cannot if they
will not then burn the place to the
ground and that's when we end up
learning the person summoned here to the
quiet council by mystique is none other
than destiny fully resurrected with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace